The Game of Thrones prequels are coming and
it brings us many legendary characters.
We have House of the Dragon and Tales of Dunk
and Egg coming our way.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
HBO is also developing a new Game of Thrones
prequel show based on George R.R. Martin’s
Tales of Dunk and Egg, which follow the adventures
of Ser Duncan the Tall (Dunk)
and young Aegon V Targaryen (Egg) 90 years
prior to the events of “A Song of Ice and
Fire.”
In this video we talk about a character that
is important in both, the Targaryen history
and the tales of Dunk and Egg (being the main
character himself), Aegon Egg Targaryen. Aegon
V Targaryen was a Lord of the Seven Kingdoms
and the fifteenth Targaryen to sit the Iron
Throne as King of the Andals, the Rhoynar,
and the First Men. In his youth, he went by
the nickname Egg and squired for Ser Duncan
the Tall. Aegon became king after a Great
Council bypassed a number of candidates earlier
in the line of succession, and after his elder
brother, Maester Aemon, refused the throne.
As the fourth son of Maekar I, himself a fourth
son, Aegon was called Aegon the Unlikely.
Aegon had large eyes which could appear dark
blue, but were actually deep and dark and
purple. The boy was pasty faced and skinny.
He shaved his hair to hide his identity while
a squire, making his eyes appear huge on his
bald head. Aegon wore a wide-brimmed floppy
straw hat while squiring for Ser Duncan the
Tall. According to a semi-canonical source,
the adult Aegon had long, shoulder-length
hair that shone like beaten gold with strands
of silver woven together. Tall, slender and
handsome, he wore the crown of Aegon III.
Aegon grew to become a kindly and approachable
man beloved by smallfolk. Maester Aemon, who
gave the nickname Egg to his brother, believed
that Aegon had innocence and sweetness.
Aegon was born the fourth son and fifth child
of Prince Maekar Targaryen and his wife, Dyanna
Dayne. Aegon served at court in King's Landing
for two years as a page, sometimes attending
to the small council. Aegon owned a dragon
egg, which was colored with green and white
swirls and had been placed in his cradle with
him when he was a babe. Aegon and his elder
brother, Prince Aemon who we all know as Maester
Aemon, hoped their eggs would hatch so they
could become dragonriders. Aegon kept his
egg at Summerhall. Aegon loathed his brother,
the cruel and sadistic Aerion. Aegon was supposed
to squire for his eldest brother, Daeron,
in the tourney at Ashford Meadow, but Daeron
had no interest in jousting and instead drank
himself into a stupor at an inn. Daeron shaved
Aegon's head to prevent the boy's distinctive
Targaryen hair from being recognized by men
sent by their father, Prince Maekar. When
the hedge knight Dunk visited the inn, he
assumed Aegon was a stableboy. Calling himself
"Egg", the disguised Aegon had assumed that
Dunk was short for "Duncan", which Dunk accepted.
Aegon was impressed by the humble hedge knight
and followed him. Ser Duncan the Tall agreed
to let Egg serve as his squire during the
tourney. Duncan was arrested and sentenced
to fight a trial by battle after attacking
Egg's elder brother, Prince Aerion Targaryen.
Duncan was accused by both Aerion and his
older brother, Prince Daeron Targaryen, who
had falsely accused Duncan of having kidnapped
Prince Aegon Targaryen. Because the battle
was to be a Trial of Seven, Aegon convinced
Ser Lyonel Baratheon to fight on behalf of
Duncan. Aegon's uncle, Prince Baelor Breakspear,
also fought alongside Duncan during the trial,
but Baelor died of a wound inflicted by Prince
Maekar, Baelor's brother and Aegon's father,
who had fought on behalf of Aerion and House
Targaryen. After Daeron was defeated and Aerion
withdrew his accusation during the trial,
Duncan was declared innocent. Maekar, the
Prince of Summerhall, wished Aegon to be trained
as a knight, but Aegon would only agree if
Duncan were the knight who trained him. When
Maekar offered Duncan a place at the garrison
of Summerhall, Dunk declined and agreed to
take Aegon on only if Aegon accompanied him
as his squire. Aegon would live humbly, but
Duncan thought it would make Aegon a better
man than his brothers, Aerion and Daeron.
Thus, Aegon served as a squire to the Duncan
under his nickname "Egg". Aegon kept his identity
secret from the public while squiring for
Duncan, and he kept hidden in his boot a signet
ring from his father, Maekar Targaryen, Prince
of Summerhall. Aegon married Lady Betha Blackwood
in 220 AC. The marriage at the time provoked
no opposition as Aegon was very low in the
line of succession. They married for love
and eventually had five children together.
Aegon named his first-born son Duncan to honor
his friend, Ser Duncan the Tall. In 221 AC,
Aegon's uncle, King Aerys I Targaryen died
with no issue and was followed on the Iron
Throne by his last living brother, Prince
Maekar Targayen. Aegon and his brothers were
summoned to court by King Maekar. According
to a semi-canon source, Aegon participated
in the suppression of the Peake Uprising in
233 AC, with Tion Lannister as his squire.
King Maekar I was killed at Starpike during
the rebellion, however. According to a semi-canon
source, the prince knighted the mortally wounded
Tywald Lannister, Tion's twin, during the
battle. With Maekar dead, it was unclear who
should be the king since two of Aegon's older
brothers had died before his father. Daeron
left a feeble-witted daughter named Vaella
and Aerion an infant son, so a Great Council
was called to choose a king. Aegon seemed
the logical choice, but many lords considered
him "half a peasant" due to his youth among
the smallfolk. The council approached Aegon's
older brother, Maester Aemon, but he refused,
stating the crown should be given to Aegon.
Aegon was crowned Lord of the Seven Kingdoms
in 233 AC when he was thirty-three years old.
During most, if not all, of Aegon V's reign,
his old friend Ser Duncan the Tall served
as Lord Commander of the Kingsguard. Aegon's
first act as king was the arrest of Lord Brynden
Rivers, the Hand of the King, for the murder
of Aenys Blackfyre, as Bloodraven had offered
Aenys safe conduct to Westeros for the Great
Council, but had Aenys executed when he arrived
in the capital. Although all were glad another
Blackfyre pretender was dead, Aegon had to
punish Lord Bloodraven to prove the word of
the Iron Throne was not worthless. Although
Brynden was sentenced to death, Aegon allowed
him to join the Night's Watch. Aegon's brother,
Maester Aemon, decided to join the Watch as
well, to prevent any plots in which he would
be used against his brother. Brynden and Aemon
were joined by many of Bloodraven's personal
guard, the Raven's Teeth, as well as prisoners
released from dungeons by the king. The end
of winter saw the return of the Blackfyre
Pretenders, with the Fourth Blackfyre Rebellion
taking place in 236 AC. Daemon III Blackfyre
attempted to seize the Iron Throne with the
Golden Company, but few rallied to his side.
Aegon and his sons rode to meet and repel
the invaders, and Duncan the Tall slew Daemon
in single combat, ending the rebellion. Aegor
Rivers, known as Bittersteel, managed to flee
with remnants of the Golden Company across
the narrow sea. Aegon V spent much of his
reign dealing with uprisings. Most of Aegon's
troubles resulted from his efforts to improve
the lives of the smallfolk, whom he had interacted
with while squiring for Duncan. Lacking the
dragons controlled by early Targaryen kings,
Aegon reluctantly compromised with the disobedient
lords on several issues. Aegon faced renewed
troubles in his reign caused by his sons.
Convinced the Targaryen practice of incestuous
marriage was harmful after spending time with
smallfolk, Aegon and his queen, Betha Blackwood,
betrothed four of their children to some of
the Great Houses of the Seven Kingdoms in
237 AC. Their eldest son and heir, Prince
Duncan, was betrothed to the daughter of Lord
Lyonel Baratheon of Storm's End. Prince Jaehaerys,
Aegon's second son, was betrothed to Lady
Celia Tully, the daughter of the Lord of Riverrun.
Aegon's youngest son, Prince Daeron, was betrothed
to Lady Olenna Redwyne of the Arbor who would
later become known to us all as Lady Olenna
Tyrell.
In addition, Aegon's eldest daughter, Princess
Shaera, was betrothed to Luthor Tyrell, the
heir to Highgarden. The proposed marriages
would have won Aegon much support for his
reforms, but his children had inherited his
willfulness and their mother's stubbornness.
Beginning in 239 AC, Prince Duncan fell in
love with and eventually wed the mysterious
Jenny of Oldstones. The prince chose his wife
over the Iron Throne and abdicated as Prince
of Dragonstone, making his younger brother,
Prince Jaehaerys, the new heir. With Duncan
refusing to marry the daughter of Lord Baratheon,
Storm's End briefly rose in rebellion, which
ended when Ser Duncan the Tall of the Kingsguard
forced Lord Lyonel to yield during trial by
combat. With Duncan marrying Jenny as precedent,
Jaehaerys and Shaera secretly wed and consummated
their marriage in 240 AC, leaving Aegon to
deal with the anger of Houses Tully and Tyrell.
Although betrothed for nine years to Lady
Olenna Redwyne, Prince Daeron broke his betrothal
in 246 AC. In 258 AC, nine outlaws, exiles,
pirates and sellswords hoping to carve out
individual kingdoms came together in the Disputed
Lands of Essos. Among these Band of Nine was
Maelys I Blackfyre, the last of the Blackfyres.
Because the outlaws had no great urgency,
King Aegon remained intent on his reign and
on dragons in particular. Against the advice
of his friends and counselors, Aegon V became
convinced that only with dragons could he
force the lords of the Seven Kingdoms to accept
his decrees that granted freedoms, rights,
and protections to the smallfolk. This eventually
led to the tragedy of Summerhall in 259 AC,
in which Aegon perished while trying to hatch
dragon eggs. His son, Prince Duncan the Small;
his friend and Lord Commander of the Kingsguard,
Ser Duncan the Tall;
and others of the royal court also perished
in the fire. Aegon was succeeded by his second
son and heir, Jaehaerys II. Many of the laws,
rights and protections King Aegon V had granted
and bestowed upon the smallfolk were later
undone during the reign of King Aerys II by
the Hand of the King, Lord Tywin Lannister.
Many interesting characters, Targaryens and
others, many legendary figures that are immortalized
in many songs and stories - all of that and
more the Game of Thrones prequel shows are
bringing to us, starting with the House of
the Dragon in 2022. Thank you so much for
watching, hope you enjoyed this video and
if you did make sure to give it a big thumbs
upand I hope to see you in the next one, peace!